regulated at least in the UK they've
regulated the prisons pretty well I do
think there is still work to be done
with sports but these are all very
individuals no they have different yeah
I'm about to get kicked out of the
league for it to be honest because I
said something about it I'll be honest I
think the the biggest issue is you're
just calling trans women men I feel like
if you had used their PC language they
probably couldn't have had as much why
but why do why do I have to because it's
like but why do I have to change why do
I have to change my language because
because again
I I wouldn't I wouldn't
that it's the same when it's what you're
born as it's your biology
it's for me it's just confusing because
if someone doesn't say anything
if you know the words in other languages
negro means black yeah Sakura is
different from [__] it doesn't matter
yeah
you just caught me yeah it's a
terminology that people use and black
people do not like when it's used by
people that are not black okay this is
class is disrespectful so
my example it doesn't need to be taken
for word for word is if you've got a
broad enough mind you'll be able to look
at the example and see that you're
calling someone a word and a phrase that
they find disrespectful could be someone
that's obese you're calling them fat if
you're a respectful person you wouldn't
call someone a terminology that offends
them if you're a disrespectful person
you won't mind because you would like to
offend people and make few people
because I don't agree with that because
I think saying if someone's fat and they
deserve to die or something I don't
think like exactly my argument was my
argument was no my argument was to call
anyone my argument was black people are
not born Negroes but trans women are
born men what are black people born they
are born as black people and what does
negro mean in other languages no no
negro negro if you go and check these do
you mean like Spanish words
I know the history but the example you
know it was used as a slur that's
different you being born as a man is not
to slow
this is a word used to explain a
biological person it's a slope
but now you guys are demanding that we
change our language
it's just confusing so I need to know if
we're talking about men or trans women
so if you're if you keep calling trans
women men I don't know what we're
talking about at a certain point we kind
of have to use these labels otherwise
this whole thing it's not it's not it's
not the original way human beings have
been thinking for the past couple of
years that's causing these problems it's
trans people being around way of
thinking no but yeah I've been around
but there has been a way of thinking for
the past couple of thousands of years
yeah it wasn't spoke about like the get
with the gay community not a lot of
people came out that they were gay for a
very long time they hid it and it's the
same with the Trans community and not
like what it is until until they until
they feel comfortable enough to discuss
their sexuality agenda they are not
gonna come out and say oh I'm this okay
I mean gay people suffered in the same
way that trans people did right everyone
assumed all the gay men in the bathrooms
are trying to [__] the kids and there
was a lot of pedophiles like we kind of
evolved our thinking from this
um and I I have a lot of empathy towards
people that are wary about their kids
being trans it's a lot and there's a lot
of discussion about whether X Y or Z is
safe and Etc
um but the reality is we did move on
from that I want to say that was like
the 90s where we were having these types
of George Michael yeah yeah
um
but then I'm also not really convinced
there is like a transgender ideology I
know this kind of upsets a lot of people
I do think that how things are is a mess
I do think in certain situations it's
not quite there yet I think in a lot of
sports it's a mess I think I I
completely understand the anxiety
especially around changing rooms because
being naked is a vulnerability and I
don't want to like I'm a CIS woman I
don't like being naked around anyone it
doesn't feel good and if if one of the
people was like a a pre-op transgender
person it would feel uncomfortable but I
feel uncomfortable all the time so I
don't know how much the base my feeling
on what should be policy I do think that
these things could be fixed easily just
[__] everyone should have their own
cubicles and but I also realized that in
a lot of situations there aren't there
isn't that yet right if you're playing
sports in a place that doesn't have
those like facilities that sucks for you
and I don't want to like disregard that
again like CIS women are particular
class transgender women are protected
class and I think people are trying to
mean protected classes we have protected
um you know when it comes to like the
law and things when it comes to sexism
and things that connectively affect us
um there are certain things that make us
protected
um but while there is for transgender
women is a little bit different well 10
different people in general but um
anyone that is a protected class is like
black people for example or
yeah
it's just different
um things that put in place
to consider that we're you know
different from a minority that's the
word I was looking for yeah
we understand what you were saying
earlier like why I should be punished
for my speech when what I'm saying is
true
so so like with the with the no I was
talking to to you because you you said
you wouldn't have like been in that
situation if you just use their pronouns
so it's like why do I have to change my
language when what I am saying is true
I'm just say so it's not necessarily
that you're wrong or that you need to
change your language I'm saying if you
want to win a flight and not necessarily
just get kicked out of the volleyball
league or kicked out of this or that you
have to adopt the way that other people
are thinking or they're just going to
completely describe disregard you and
you might see that as being really
unfair but
the world is you have to adapt to the
way that other people are being so that
you can play them at their game and if
you don't do that they just don't care
and they're not going to engage with you
they're going to get rid of you and to
be fair calling a trans woman a man is
kind of transphobic I can't I get like
it is
but that but they are
they're a biological man but they've
transitioned to a trans woman I think
it's it's fine and and you know in in
personal relationships like I mean I'm
not gonna call someone their opposite
pronoun like when I meet them yeah when
you know the mirror yeah but but I'm but
I'm saying like I can't tweet that I
don't want men in our locker rooms I
can't tweet that I don't want men in our
sport but you could I don't want
transgender women in my locker but what
I'm saying is true though and there
shouldn't even be like a butt you could
phrase it like that like why do we have
to change our speech when we're talking
about things that are true it's because
even if you don't think that trans women
are women they're also not really men
anymore either so they're kind of
they're their own thing like and they're
under the umbrella so I see women as an
umbrella term okay so like CIS women are
there but trans women are under this
umbrella and I do think they they are a
protected class they they suffer from a
lot of things that we do some to a worse
extent like the the rate of death for
black Trans women is really bad
especially in America
it's like they do suffer a lot and I do
appreciate these things have you seen
the rate of death of men
uh death of men yes
by other men no just the rate of death
of men because I just think they
probably the Rope alone this whole thing
is the censorship I think if I was
talking about murder rather than yeah no
no I I again but I just think the real
problem is censorship I think trans
women trans people should be allowed to
do whatever they want but you can't
censor other people's opinions no you
can't yeah that's wrong I'm not saying
that oil should be censored I'm saying
but that's basically what the policies
and Society is doing they're censoring
people even from what you're saying the
way you've been saying like well you
should phrase it different why can't we
just say it how we want to see you can't
say it but you just need to be aware
that you may cause offense and if you're
happy to do that and happy to receive
the backlash
I don't care about offense that's cool
people can be offended my issue is when
I'm I'm now getting kicked out of a
league and now I'm getting other
repercussions because I said something
that's true because some people might
want to it might not want to endorse you
so some organizations might not want to
endorse you knowing that you have yeah
and I and I think and I think that's
wrong and that's why in the same way
even even if someone if someone was a
super far leftist like if you you played
on my you know maybe you're kind of left
but like on my volleyball league like I
think it's wrong that they be that they
cannot play because of an opinion I mean
I agree I mean like I do music and I
think that you know within the art the
art the Artistry world and all of that
stuff you know people want you to have
like a certain type of personality and
be super friendly and all that stuff and
kind of being nonchalant and and private
doesn't really get people anywhere so I
I agree that you know certain things
should be separated you know you should
separate who an individual is to what
they do because sometimes in my opinion
some of the
some of the most magnificent people are
weird and that's what makes them so
magnificent because they're different
they're a little bit strange to some
people you know and I think it's okay
for everyone to have an opinion it's
okay for everyone to speak about their
opinion you know these debates are good
you know it spreads awareness it spreads
knowledge but we have to also be aware
that sometimes we're going to cause
offense you know what I mean to some
people yeah I don't know I don't care
not just that don't agree with us but
it's the way in which we we word things
it's the way in which we say things you
know we can put on like you said we can
put our opinions across in a way that
doesn't cause offense people will listen
to me like okay you only really get to
pick offensive or actually productive
you can't really do both and it's fine
if you want to say things the way we
can't we can't wear it our only two
options are offensive and productive if
you don't seem reasonable to the other
party then I'll go oh yeah but I can't
help how I seem like I can't help their
feelings and and at the end of the day
it's like if we're talking about things
that are true they're true and I can't
help I can't help that I can't help out
someone else feels about a fact about
something that is true transplant and
it's not necessarily about feelings but
it's like enough of the population has
agreed on a let's just say societal
whatever no I I think it's a small
percentage of the population that's
pushing the society if you're engaging
with that small percentage of the
population and they're in charge of
governing bodies that affect your sport
well yeah and that's the issue in the
middle and the issue is is that they get
in charge of these organizations when I
was interviewing girls at the tournament
a lot of people didn't agree with it a
lot of people were against it but they
can't say anything because
um yeah because of these yeah because of
the governing bodies so it's like I
can't even speak out that I don't want
them in my sports I mean and if I'm
being honest and no but the the issue is
like this language I'm sorry it's so
confusing to the average person's CIS
Tran I'm sorry I'm not even trying to be
rude it's confusing
gender fluid
all these words gender fluids
I don't know what any of this means
no but then there's this then there's
there's non-binary gender flu
doesn't really matter that much it
doesn't but what if you're calling you
know aside from it just being [__]
confusing because we do need to
differentiate you do it's because of
what you're saying you want to you want
to differentiate otherwise
a man and then if you've transitioned
you're called a trans woman no I don't
want new language
I want the same language we've used for
the last 500 years okay transgender has
existed for how many years
so it's new right in the 80s
degrees as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible